there's a porn lady her name is Mia
Khalifa
Mia Khalifa is a political activist but
she's also a porn lady I don't know if
she still does porn or if she only
previously did porn but she has all
sorts of opinions that are not very good
and she spouts off on politics sometimes
and she's just given her worst opinion
yet this is her opinion on divorce
oh we're comparing stats baby girl
doesn't know that I am Tom Brady at this
game
married at 18 divorced at 21 second
marriage married at 25 divorced at 28.
third engagement engaged at 29 ended it
at 30 but I kept the ring I'm still
keeping Tom Brady on his toes
we should not be afraid to leave these
men we are not stuck with these people
marriage is not a sanctimonious thing it
is it is paperwork it's something it's
it's it's a commitment you make to
someone but if you feel like
you're not getting anything from that
commitment and you're trying you gotta
go you gotta go you have to go I know
it's difficult to fill out paperwork and
to make appointments and to do all of
these things but this is your life do
you want to be stuck with someone
it's period
so not great advice
generally speaking probably not the
wisest thing to take advice on marriage
from a prostitute or or even forget the
prostitute for a second probably best
not to take advice on marriage from
people who have had multiple failed
marriages
I'm not knocking her we live in a messed
up culture she's made all sorts of bad
decisions but we also live in a very
pornographic culture that just seduces
women into this kind of a lifestyle you
see this especially with the
democratization of porn through things
like only fans you see it in the Andrew
take case
this guy Andrew Tate whatever charges he
was brought up on in Romania I don't
even really care
he's a pimp he's a pimp who brags on
camera about seducing women which in a
wiser older age seduction was considered
not only
not less severe than than a physical
violation like rape but actually more
egregious because while rape violates
the body
rather egregious seduction violates the
soul and the intellect so now we just
think that's all fine because our only
moral Criterion for political judgment
is consent
but no we live in a culture that seduces
these young girls into all of this
nonsense in in the way that we see
particularly with Andrew Tate who says
oh yeah I trick these girls into falling
in love with me and then I'd pimp them
out and have them do tricks so I'd make
a lot of money and then I'd rip them off
and put them in a house in Romania and
have film videos of themselves and he's
bragging about it at least you see that
kind of transparency I mean the more I
to paraphrase nor McDonald the more I
hear about the Sandra Tate fella the
more he sounds like a real jerk but our
whole culture does that it's not just
Andrew Tate he's just one guy it's the
whole culture seduces women into porn
right now go to puretalk.com Knowles you
know a company is looking out for you
when they actually upgrade your service
and don't charge you for it this is
great news for new and current Pure Talk
customers pure talk just added data to
every plan and includes a mobile hotspot
with no price increase whatsoever if
you've considered pure talk before but
have not made the switch take a look
again for just 20 bucks a month you will
get unlimited talk text and now 55 zero
percent more 5G data plus their new
mobile hotspot this is one of the many
reasons I love pure talk it's veteran
owned they only hire the best customer
service team located right here in the
US of a that alone is worth the switch
most families are saving almost a
thousand dollars a year while enjoying
the most Dependable 5G Network in
America remember you vote with how you
spend your money so stop supporting
local wireless companies that don't
support you when you go to puretalk.com
Knowles you will save an additional
fifty five zero percent off your first
month because they value you go to
puretalk.com wireless for Americans buy
Americans right now go to genucel.com
Knowles kwles is that a dark spot on
your face is it is that what I see over
there is it still bothering you what
about those liver spots on your hands
neck and chest well now
you can watch them disappear safely and
quickly in just three minutes
introducing the genucel Dark Spot
Corrector their three-step three-minute
dark spot luxury system does exactly
what it sounds like by using their
Crystalis
microdermabrasion before the Dark Spot
Corrector and finishing with a touch of
collagen building geniusell 15 you will
see the dark spots disappear before your
very eyes instantly smoothly luxuriously
I also just love this company because
the owner is a Founder rather is a
Coptic Christian who left Egypt for the
American dream head on over to
genucelp.com
Knowles ordered the new dark spot
treatment system today say goodbye to
those pesky spots tomorrow
genucel.com
Knowles you can get your geniusell bags
and puffiness serum also included right
now geniusell's most popular package for
seventy seven zero percent off
genucel.com
I'm really not knocking this out Mia
Khalifa but
this is a weird thing in society today
where we
we take advice from people who have no
credibility on these issues we've just
lost our sense of authority
even you see this in the reflexive uh
response against authoritarianism on the
left and on the right we just hate all
authority and so we just we recoil into
our own individualism we we exalt
individual conscience and judgment above
all things this is a product of the
Enlightenment in the liberal age it's a
product that we see on the left it's a
product that we see on the right but
it's wrong there are legitimate
authorities
to whom we should listen
our parents uh wise teachers the
Traditions that have endured throughout
the ages the moral law the natural law
the the church the
true there is Authority that we ought to
recognize Authority is not a bad thing I
know the a word is very nasty in our
modern culture but Authority is not a
bad thing and you can't escape it you're
going to make a judgment somewhere so
either you're going to follow good wise
just prudent legitimate authorities or
you're going to listen to your own
extremely imperfect
moral reasoning with your very imperfect
faculties of reason
or you're going to listen to people who
have no credibility at all
like porn people
on marriage and
political Crux like the bidens on
corruption and our sacred democracy in
our justice system and so on and so
forth you're not going to fix this
problem at the very basic political
level of marriage or the macro political
level of the state by
neglecting by denying legitimate
Authority hi Michael this is one of your
based listeners and I'm based because
I'm Greek Orthodox and because I'm Greek
Orthodox I wanted to ask you your
thoughts again on whether or not animals
go to heaven I know you believe that
they don't as a Catholic but I would
like to reference Revelation 21 5 that
says God will make all things new and I
was wondering if that would have any
role to play in your belief in whether
or not animals go to heaven so I hope
that you change your mind I'd love to
hear your thoughts
I'm sorry my dear Fido does not go to
heaven
Fido does not go to heaven because Fido
does not have a rational Soul Fido has a
soul proper to his nature
but his nature is not rational and his
soul is not Eternal there will be I
suspect animals in the new creation
there will be a new Heaven and a new
Earth
uh but it won't be Fido I'm sorry to say
we love our pets while they're here and
they provide us all sorts of comfort I'm
told I don't really like pets I'm a
people person as you know but uh no they
don't sorry
as as a friend of mine has said before
facts don't care about your feelings
facts don't care about your Fido boy
what a great clip that was now make sure
make sure that you ring that Bell
subscribe
to my YouTube channel we'll see you next
time